hello and welcome back to deepmind the
podcast
[Music]
over the last two episodes we've been
exploring deepmind's goal of solving
intelligence asking what that actually
means and traveling along some of the
roads that could take us there
this time it's all about the robots
we'll be exploring the idea of physical
intelligence and to do that i'll be
taking you behind the scenes of the
robotics lab in kings cross london
you've got three
humanoid robots they're black they've
got a very sort of cuboid body but they
have arms and legs and even little tiny
heads they're quite small though they're
probably the size of a large chicken
yeah smaller than a goose
i'm hannah fry and this is episode four
let's get physical
now before our robotics lab passes are
activated let me fill you in on a bit of
background
why would a company known for getting
machines to play board games and fold
proteins find robotics so alluring
in june last year i emerged bright eyed
from my lockdown induced hibernation to
visit cheltenham a pretty spa town in
south west england
the cheltenham science festival an
annual event attracting the world's
leading scientists and thinkers was the
setting for my first in-person interview
since the kovid 19 lockdown
and as luck would have it my interviewee
was rya hadsell deepmind's director of
robotics ah it's very nice to be in a
room full of people again freddie
ryan owes pretty much all there is to
know about robotics and artificial
intelligence starting with the
difference between them
when we think about artificial
intelligence a lot of the time people
immediately go to a robot as being the
instantiation of that ai
just think about the robots you see in
films c3po wally marvin their paranoid
android
they're all intelligent beings with
robot bodies
they're all able to reason about their
environment and make decisions
likewise our visions of super
intelligent ai long into the future is
rarely just a disembodied voice
apart from a couple of exceptions like
in the film her for example
robots and ai are synonymous with one
another in many people's minds but
really the two should be distinguished
ai is a computer program that's usually
trained on a lot of data to be able to
give answers to questions in a similar
way that a human might so think about
being able to translate from french to
english to mandarin these are the types
of problems that an ai might be able to
do
a robot on the other hand takes actions
and changes the world either
manipulation through touching the world
and moving things around maybe doing
assembly or a robot that can move itself
around and then we can think about the
two together as a.i being a really
natural way to bring us to the next set
of breakthroughs for what robots can do
if you heard the first series of this
podcast you'll already be familiar with
the idea that robots don't necessarily
come with ai built into them
your dishwasher your lawn mower your
pressure cooker are all in the technical
sense
robots
they are machines that are capable of
carrying out a series of actions
automatically
but these aren't the sorts of robots
that deepmind is interested in as a
route to artificial general intelligence
instead
their robots use machine learning
techniques to learn for themselves how
to perform different tasks
so what does all of this look like what
kind of robots are being trained to
saunter around the research facilities
to ground algorithmic experience in the
real world and explore the absolute
cutting edge of physical intelligence
well
why don't you come on in
welcome back to the robotics lab
[Music]
meet akil raju a software engineer on
the robotics team
you can see the excitement in his eyes
as he shows me around the lab even while
the rest of his face is covered by a
mask
so this is going to be a little bigger
than the last time oh gosh massive whoa
yeah you know if you ever go to a trade
show and they have like little stalls up
in a giant space it sort of looks a
little bit like that so we're in this
big concrete building
with lots of glass
along one side and then you've got these
little booths all the way along with
i mean they sort of look like privacy
screens but privacy for the humans
exactly the robots no one cares about
the process yeah
inside these mini booths are robotic
arms of every size and shape imaginable
tall crane-like arms short and stubby
ones and arms with grippers on the end
like the kind you'll see in a games
arcade
all of these arms are part of deepmind's
research into getting robots to
dexterously manipulate everyday objects
akeel ushered me into one of the booths
to take a closer look
so this big arm that is extending out of
a table
you know those stand mixers that you get
in posh kitchens
imagine one of those but like a giant
version so it's kind of quite bulbous
and curvaceous with all of these joints
and cameras attached to it and then
right on the end there's a teeny tiny
key and it's i guess trying to put a key
in a lock yep exactly
this robot has
kind of this attachment where it can
insert
like a usb in a usb hole or maybe a key
or so on and so we're trying to learn
how to actually do very like fine
manipulation we're taking
tasks that you might do in everyday life
and we're using that as a challenge
if you wanted
to have one of these robots in a factory
say doing this really fine insertion
task why can't you just pre-program one
why does it need to be
something that has trained itself if it
was a case where
it's very fixed settings we know exactly
where the key is we know exactly where
the hole is then probably yeah you can
just program it the thing is
that's not how all factories really are
a lot of factories that might require
some kind of an insertion task like
putting a key in a lock
we'll also have a lot of variables at
play so that the lock and key aren't at
precisely the same start points each
time
and that changes the challenge from
being something pre-programmable
to something much harder
and what you'll notice actually is
when
these types of insertions need to happen
in a factory it's not robots that do it
in the real world now it's humans and
that's another reason why we chose
insertions as a task
because it's
somewhat unsolved by the greater
robotics community
you might be wondering how on earth any
of this is possible how do you possibly
set up an inanimate robot arm to teach
itself to open a lock
well by now it probably won't surprise
you that one of the fundamental methods
for training physical intelligence is
that deep mind favorite approach
reinforcement learning
in the simplest terms this involves
rewarding an algorithm with points for
accomplishing a task like correctly
inserting a key into a lock
and there is a reason why robotics is
geared up for algorithms based on
reinforcement learning
here's doina precup head of deepmind's
montreal office she is a world expert in
reinforcement learning
it's very easy to imagine expressing
robotics tasks in a reward language
because you can observe when the robot
is doing the correct thing let's say
putting an object in a particular place
and so it's very easy to phrase the
problem as a reinforcement learning
problem
and of course we know from the natural
world animals train by reward to do
complicated physical tasks would like to
take that idea to robotics as well
if you want to get a dog to go fetch you
don't carefully explain how it should
move each one of its muscles in order to
run towards an object retrieve it and
give it back to you instead you reward
it with a treat when it does what you
want and it learns by itself how best to
calibrate its body in the performance of
that task
in this way some of the algorithms
inside ai robots are much like dogs
except they're rewarded with numbers not
tasty biscuits
this might make it seem like
reinforcement learning is a magic bullet
but in practice things are a bit more
complicated
physical tasks like inserting a key into
a lock are subject to a problem known as
sparse reward if you waited to reward a
robot until it had successfully put a
key into a lock just by chance you would
be waiting around for a long time
so the robotics team has been looking
for other ways of putting their robots
on the right track
while the robot is learning to do it a
human comes in and when it gets close
but no cigar a human can take over and
just be like adjust like this maybe move
to the left a little bit
and so while we might have a sparse
reward so it's kind of like it's all or
nothing you know you're in the locker
you're not in it
what the robot will use is both that
information of sparsity but also maybe
information from a human and kind of the
combination of those things is how it
might learn
and while there are certainly areas
where learning algorithms like this one
have been able to successfully
accomplish tasks you shouldn't be fooled
into thinking this stuff is easy
because not all the robots in this lab
are quite as accomplished
when i was here last i saw a robot that
was stacking lego bricks
not to be rude i wouldn't say it was the
most impressive thing i've ever seen in
my life
how's it doing now we can actually move
to the other side of the lab and we can
start to see that stuff
akiel took me to another robot cell with
a red and black robot arm inside
it had a gripper on the end with two
appendages a bit like the grabby bit of
a litter picker and it was hovering over
a tray containing a trio of 3d shapes
its goal was to learn how to stack the
red pyramid shape on top of the blue
octagonal prism
so there's only one way around that it
can hold this red object and
successfully pick it up
and it has a workshop which way and
unfortunately every time it tries to
rotate and pick it up oh hang on i think
it's got it it's got it
it's good job these things don't get
disheartened because my goodness it's
been how many years since i've been here
no this time it's been here trying and
trying and trying so we're seeing
something that's kind of training right
now so we're not seeing our best don't
make excuses
why are these dexterous manipulation
tasks so important to learn
so one of the reasons that we have a
robotics lab at deepmind is really to
ground our search for agi in the real
world to make sure that
our progress towards agi is true agi
like if we find agi it probably should
be able to
stack an object on another object and
speaking of objects next to this row of
robot arms i noticed a basket full of
children's toys rubber ducks foam
bananas and a much-loved cartoon
character i noticed spongebob is still
here sat in the corner this time there's
also hang on little green rubber ducks
what is the idea behind this stuff so
these kind of play things are really
nice because manipulating objects that
can bend and move and stuff like that
that's a new type of physics that our
agents need to learn somewhere in a
landfill is there a pile of sort of
crushed foam bananas that robots have
we haven't destroyed any bananas yet i
can you haven't destroyed any banana i
don't believe that for a second
[Music]
as fun as it is to watch these robot
arms try and fail to insert usb sticks
into computers and sling foam bananas
around
it's worth remembering that the projects
on display in the robotics lab serve an
important purpose
building ai that can interact with the
physical world
is considered central to the overarching
goal of solving intelligence itself
here's ryan hatzel again speaking at the
cheltenham science festival when we
think about human intelligence a lot of
the time we focus on things like
language or our cognitive skills how
good we are at math
but really a lot of our brain has been
developed in order to just move our
bodies and so i think that that level of
intelligence motor intelligence movement
intelligence this is a core part of our
intelligence and that's what our
cognitive skills are built on top of
this focus on creating intelligent
robots which can learn for themselves
is part of the reason why deep minds
robots might seem a little bit
well
rudimentary compared to what else is out
there because i'm sure that all of you
are thinking about those videos on the
internet of robots doing backflips being
pushed over getting back up performing
all kinds of incredibly sophisticated
movements
so i thought i'd ask ryan hadsell about
this
you can't believe everything you see on
the internet hannah
welfare you're absolutely right there
are robots that can do some pretty
impressive stuff that can flip that can
jump at deepmind we've been focusing
more on the generality aspect of it the
g in agi
we want robots that can learn new things
that they've never done before without
needing somebody to program them just
through experience or through watching a
human so those very impressive videos
the ones that aren't fake of robot zoo
backflips they are essentially
following a very precise
set of instructions is that essentially
what we're saying absolutely and they
tend to be a demonstration of what that
actual robot can do a robot that can do
a backflip that's very impressive
because of the power and mass ratio
that's required to do that but it's very
different from wanting that robot to
do a new skill that it has just observed
for the first time it couldn't walk over
to a table and pick up a coffee cup for
example it could not well you've
disappointed me right
but yours could in theory in future ours
could do that and
weed potatoes and pick tomatoes as well
this is the key point here if robots can
teach themselves to manipulate objects
and move around they can be adaptable
and offer assistance to humans in a
whole host of critical tasks
including situations where they can't
currently support us
so this came up when there was the
fukushima disaster in japan there's been
an explosion at a japanese nuclear power
station damaged in yesterday's massive
earthquake clouds of smoke could be seen
rising above the fukushima nuclear site
people realized that we didn't have a
good way
to
send robots into this extremely
dangerous radioactive area and make
repairs
because all of our robots either
required an area that was easily
accessible or didn't have the necessary
dexterity to for instance shut a valve
or open a door and so there was a whole
robotics program aimed at how do we
improve legged locomotion into areas
where a wheeled robot can't go and how
do we improve the dexterity of robots as
well
of course there is a flip side here if
in the future these artificially
intelligent robots are good enough to be
deployed in the real world for saving
human lives
they could also be built to do the
opposite
robots have been used to carry weapons
and so if you make a more capable robot
then potentially what you're making is a
more capable vehicle for holding weapons
of course deep mind is very much against
autonomous weaponry including on robots
and i think that the benefits of robots
and what they can do in our world
outweigh these risks especially if the
world stands strongly against the use of
weaponry and robotics
and this is not the only ethical concern
about robotics research
lots of people are worried about the
possible detrimental effects of
automation on the workforce
what we're looking at now with the use
of robots would be to augment humans
somebody working on a construction site
that has a robot next to them that's
able to do some of the heavy lifting for
instance so it's not about displacing
humans or replacing them it's about
enhancing what a human can do
any robot that's going to help with
weeding potatoes and picking tomatoes
will of course need to have mastered
locomotion
back at the deepmind robotics lab a
recent focus has been to develop a robot
which can move around on two legs a
problem which comes with its own unique
set of research challenges
on the floor we've got what looks sort
of like the play mat that you put down
for kids
akil showed me a sort of
robot play pen about nine meters squared
with a barrier around it presumably to
stop the robots inside from escaping so
inside this square then you've got three
humanoid robots they're black they've
got a very cuboid body but they have
arms and legs and even little tiny heads
they're quite small though i should tell
you that they're probably the size of a
large chicken
yeah smaller than a goose bigger than a
chicken i don't know
and basically what we've been doing is
learning to walk around and so like
robot actually learns to kind of use its
legs even its arms
the head has a camera so let's kind of
look around and see what's going on
so it is very much kind of almost like a
whole body control problem in some sense
can i touch it
oh my gosh okay
oh it's quite heavy it's got these
little handles on the back almost like a
rucksack and lots of ports like little
usb ports and an ethernet cable port and
stuff
and then for feet it's got these little
skid pads almost like it's going skiing
but just with really short skis it's
very pretty
so i'm lifting its arm up now and it
kind of returns to center but it's got
this really like smooth action have a
listen to that
i feel really sad sort of like oh please
leave me alone
okay it's walking around
imagine if you were doing a really
rubbish robot dance in a nightclub that
is exactly what it looks like it looks
like it should fall over
so you haven't programmed this to walk
around in a circle no this was learned
on the robot just by learning from the
data over a couple of days that's jan
huntlik a research scientist at deepmind
who's been following the progress of
these humanoid robots for more than a
year
did you teach it to fall flat on its
back like it just did no it just falls
it's quite good at pushing yourself up
though
yeah so those things are programmed the
pushing behavior to stand up that's
programmed because otherwise you just
spent your entire life picking up the
robot well either we need to pick them
up or they would need to learn to stand
up we are kind of humanizing them by
giving them names
the eureka protrochen is another
research scientist on the locomotion
project
what their names are these three i think
one of them is england and one is messi
from the messi the footballer and mine's
called [ __ ]
that's from humane deji or the hajj the
great romanian footballer
just because i'm from romania originally
so if you look at that one this is a
completely different training process
and you can see that the gate is very
different
and it can try to walk backwards and
it's actually
looks like it's a drunk robot so it's
trying to walk backwards but it's sort
of um
i must say i could have stood watching
these cute and mostly completely
hopeless little humanoid robots all day
but i wanted to find out more about the
process of training them to walk
so after waving goodbye to england messi
and co i asked jan and viarika about
their experience of training these
robots in their living rooms at home
when the pandemic hit
how did it travel does it just pop in a
little suitcase actually if you buy it
you get it with a suitcase it comes with
it so it can travel do you have quite a
big living room
not that big but yeah i'm adapting it i
have a pen there with floor mats and
foam walls so when you watch tv at night
time you sort of put your feet up and
around you is a little robot pen exactly
yeah we even had experiments where the
robot was watching tv did you really
well we wanted to run some experiments
to test
visual networks tv is a good source of
diverse visual data and it's already in
the living room right so why not
so hang on your job
for the last year has been still on the
sofa and watch tv with your robots not
quite that but
probably a few seconds of it it does
look like that yeah
so how do you train a humanoid robot to
walk again the underlying mechanism is
reinforcement learning the robots are
rewarded with points for forward
velocity and not falling over
when you haven't given them any training
what do they do oh they don't do much
they just start shaking for one second
or two at most and then they fall
after
training for a few hours then they start
actually walking like taking a few steps
and then later on they bump into walls
and then using vision they learn how to
avoid the walls so i i have a
two-year-old at home right and like the
way you're describing here it's not
dissimilar from the way that the
two-year-old has learned to walk there's
a lot of falling not that
shaking and flailing but there was also
sort
much
a lot of walking into walls do you see
those similarities with the way that
these robots learn to walk in the way
that toddlers learn there are some
similarities where probably for toddlers
even before they crawl they still
discover their body they still learn to
move their limbs
whereas our robots we just put them in
standing position and now walk
and how quickly did it manage to learn
to walk i think in about 24 hours it was
already walking for me that's impressive
not 24 hours in real time but 24 hours
in sort of training time yeah yeah that
spans about a week of training but uh
training like a small uh
sessions before something breaks or
taking it to the lab for a quick repair
or something like that
the eureka raises an important point
about the fragility of these robots
the actual hardware is not designed for
a machine learning technique which
involves a robot falling down loads of
times before any progress is made
here's ryan hansel to explain
the robots that are built today are not
built for the type of learning paradigms
that we think is key to developing agi
think about when
a child learns to walk every time they
fall down
they then heal from that and they keep
on going
there's only so many times that a robot
can fall down before it simply breaks
this approach comes with all kinds of
difficulties and hurdles that the
pre-programmed robots just don't have to
worry about
here's jan humplik again
the main limitation is that you really
start from scratch with more classical
approaches you perhaps don't need any
data it's just going to work out of the
box
so these are
certainly disadvantages of reinforcement
can't you cheat though can't what one
robot has learned about the world be
imparted onto another absolutely and
there are many different ways to share
knowledge in particular you can just
have multiple robots collecting data and
this is really the way to scale up this
data collection process
what yarn is talking about here is a
technique called pooling instead of [ __ ]
and england learning to walk
independently of each other their data
how many times they fell over what their
sensor readings were when they fell etc
is regularly uploaded to a central
controller which combines this
information and feeds it back to each
robot so that they can better navigate
the world based on their combined
learning experience
we can track each robot how well they're
doing and yeah we definitely discuss
like oh okay my robot starts falling
more often now is yours the same did it
get quite competitive
i kept telling everybody that it's not a
competition
but yes every time somebody would cheat
the learning curve and there would be
the two robots they would be like oh
viorika is winning oh yanni is winning
i'm like no no
we're only winning if the performances
are the same on both robots
speaking of teamwork there are other
environments beyond just walking around
or inserting keys into locks or stacking
bricks that serve as an important test
project for the robots a chance to hone
in on a set of robot skills that would
be useful to have in the long term
for that in true deep mind fashion their
focus has turned to games and one in
particular
the beautiful game
in order to play football you have to be
able to control your body
you need to be able to run to walk
but then you also need to have these
skills of dribbling and shooting
and then at even a level above that you
need to have the coordination and the
strategy over the whole game so it's
really a challenge that has a lot of
layers to it
so far deepmind has been teaching
football not to real robots but to
simulated ones computerized avatars in
human form a bit like a simplified
version of the players in your favorite
video game
the difference with these players is
that their repertoire of movements is
not pre-programmed but like the real
robots they are effectively learning to
move from scratch the point is not to
have robots playing at wembley stadium
in the near future however fun that
might be
we're really trying to study whether
it's valuable to train these methods
using reward and the competition of
something like football or whether there
are other ways to train for this type of
behavior
underneath that big umbrella of
reinforcement learning it's helpful to
use a series of other techniques to get
the agents up and running
here they're also using something called
imitation learning which involves
gathering video footage from real human
football matches using motion capture to
translate the movements of each player's
joints into a dataset and then training
a neural network so that these simulated
humanoids begin to mimic the movements
of real players
so this is really layering these
different types of learning algorithms
together
and the exciting thing is that the
result in the end is four agents that
can race around this field and they've
really achieved this level of whole body
control and also
team coordination
and then raya showed me my first ever
video of a simulated humanoid football
match
and i'll do my best to commentate on the
highlights
so here we are for this season's title
decider between these two titans of ai
football the blues versus humanoids
united playing in red
well the game's begun and drogbot has it
for the blues cuts inside and then chops
back onto his right but look the ball is
broken free and robo naldo is clear
go
well they say a week is a long time in
politics but five seconds really is an
epoch in ai football
as impressive as this video is right i
think it's fair to say that at certain
points they are quite hilariously bad at
controlling their bodies
yeah i mean they are
not trying to win any points on style or
grace
so that really lets the agent optimize
for just purely trying to achieve at
school it doesn't matter if the arms are
flailing around so you can see the
problem with putting this onto a real
robot yeah i can see how that would be a
problem with the robots
it's in the game of football that we
start to see the different flavors of
intelligence converge
training agents to play football gives
them physical skills like dribbling and
passing but when combined with a
reinforcement learning algorithm which
rewards them for team play you start to
see emerging the sort of cooperative ai
we heard about in the previous episode
the question is if physical and social
intelligence can be developed in tandem
in this way could physical intelligence
provide a path all the way to agi
it all depends on how you define agi
doesn't it i've noticed this a lot yes
maybe not immediately you know if you
look at evolution it's a very long path
to go from initial creatures to human
beings then i think also it could be a
very long path if we want to
build an agi starting from first
principles of learning to move a body
but that is what we are looking at
jan humplik also believes that it will
be a long time before robotics takes us
to a general form of intelligence
if i ask somebody on the street what
would they be impressed by the robot
doing they would say something like well
you know maybe cleaning my apartment and
and if you start thinking about this
problem you're like okay so it certainly
needs to use vision it certainly needs
to understand human language because you
need to give it command
it needs to understand what does it mean
to clean the apartment and that's not
trivial because cleaning doesn't mean
destroying your furniture
solving anything impressive like this
essentially getting very close to agi
but if embodied intelligence social
intelligence and linguistic intelligence
don't necessarily lead to agi on their
own
is there a single path that does
well some deep mind researchers are
convinced that there is
and it's been staring us in the face
this whole time when we say that reward
is enough we're really arguing that all
of the abilities of intelligence
everything from
perception to knowledge to social
intelligence to language can be
understood
as a single process
of trying to increase the rewards that
that agent gets if this hypothesis was
true it would mean that we only need to
solve one problem in intelligence rather
than a thousand different problems for
each of the separate abilities
that's next time on the deepmind podcast
presented by me hannah fry and produced
by dan hardoon at whistle down
productions
if you like what you've heard please do
rate and review the podcast helps others
who are also ai curious to find it
same time next week